i like throwing some curveballs at the
beginning i promise these are easy i
think um if you guys could get the
financing to make anything you want what
would you make and why
i mean not to sound whatever but like i
think he is doing exactly what he wants
to do i think he's actually in a
position of being able to to dream of of
yeah kind of the the
i would go back and make this movie
again
if i could and i remember that when we
finished the movie when we wrapped i
told you that i would keep shooting this
film
for another two or three months easily
it just was such an incredible
experience i didn't want to finish that
he's like i just did that
um
yeah and if i were to green light
anything right now it would probably be
the movie that i would like to make i'm
i'm gonna direct a movie soon called the
chronology of water and that's like not
and not like shamelessly plugging that
because it's nothing to fly it's a small
thing
but if somebody handed me money to make
that right now i would
jump for joy
i understand you guys um if someone has
never seen anything that you have ever
done what is the project you what is the
thing that you want them to start with
well
i
i mean maybe like start with
i'm like watch every movie i've ever
made start with the safety of objects
get all the way to spencer please before
you have any i'm like see everything
i've ever done
[Laughter]
yeah
um no i don't know that's like um if i
just like one thing spencer at this
point and definitely this one
maybe backwards yeah i i did a very
i did a movie that i don't think other
people have seen that i love that's
called postmortem
so that would probably be my choice
what do you think it is jumping into why
i get to talk to you guys today what do
you think it actually is about diana
that has kept her in the limelight and
so many people care about her so many
years after she's gone
i mean i think she jutted out of an
institution that has uh
uh
kind of infamously stiff upper lip
obviously the the entire royal family
upholds an ideal and an identity that is
starkly
in really just very different from what
diana energetically brings to the table
um i think that
there are certain people that are born
in this world
that have a talent like a real physical
and emotional talent to bring people
together and
her kind of isolation
was something she wore
and was really visible in on on her skin
and i think people
just intrinsically sensed that and
wanted to
be human and and and get close to that
person and i think that it was just sort
of this like mutual contagious
craving for human connection that made
everyone go we're here for you i mean
that's what people do for each other and
um
yeah i just think the stark contrast
of that in in a royal setting
was was pretty foundationally rocking
it's it's empathy i think empathy
george a person that was
born to privilege was born in you know
in the very unusual particular
circumstances
and
[Music]
and for some reason she was very normal
and regular and people could see
themselves on her
and things that the things that she went
through
they were just normal and
and her pains are
most people's pains and her joys were
more people's joys and
it's a very mysterious thing but there's
there's obviously an element of of an
incredible amount of humanity and and
that's
that's why i guess that the movies also
tries to to work with
kristin i think you're one of the few
people on the planet who maybe could
understand a little bit of what diana
went through in terms of the paparazzi
the magazines like focus on you did that
actually help you in playing the role
yeah i mean she's she was has been
deemed the most hunted
person of of you know our era and um
i think that
our movie
very much examines the jailbreak aspect
of her life and and her kind of
sprinting swiftly towards having
uh a life that was connected to her and
an outer life an exterior life that
connected and was more in balance with
her in her life
and um
i guess
i have a hard time comparing
my experience with hers because
i'm not running away from anything i'm
i'm kind of moving towards
people and i mean look like of course
like i'm not like begging paparazzi to
come hang out with me every day that
that is annoying but it is it's just
they're looking at me for such different
reasons that i
i don't feel as
i just
i just don't feel as taken from it in in
in such a way i i feel uh
also that she was just somebody who um
there's a huge dichotomy in terms of her
relationship with being photographed
because on one's and on one hand she she
loved it on the other hand it was just
like she couldn't actually be her
completely true self all the time
therefore the pictures feel fraudulent
and uh i'm very lucky that i'm allowed
to be a real person i don't have a royal
title i don't have to uphold some sort
of like farcical ideal i get to make
mistakes and choices and do them freely
and sort of move towards people that
attract me in art and uh
yeah i get to be a little more sprawling
so i it's hard for me to compare i do
know what it feels like to always kind
of go like i'm pretty sure people are
looking at me right now but the reasons
are so foundationally different that
it's hard it's like kind of apples and
oranges
i completely get it uh pablo i really
enjoyed your aesthetic choices in this
film the way you shot it the camera
moves and the choice of music can you
sort of talk about um
the choices you made especially with the
camera working the music
well in terms of the camera work with
with with claire muthon our
cinematographer
we made two very simple choices at the
beginning one
it was to be really really close
from
to christian like physically close
that means it's very close like here
and
and
and then the other one that i
that i made to myself was to
avoid any type of artificial fireworks
and be very simple
and be in the story and with the
characters and specifically with with
diana i felt that
the movie would only succeed if if we
were able to have the audience
experience what she was experiencing and
and that is about you know simplicity
and proximity
there are things that are that that of
course we try to
make them beautiful and and they have
their their lenses and camera movements
and
but it's all really chasing the tone and
the mood of the film and of course
there's uh an incredible
work made by johnny greenwood and that
really helps that and
the combination of the baroque music
with the jazz
created an incredible
friction with with both the picture and
sound that that just elevated the the
result into something that is different
that
he has obviously the the baroque style
that
it's it feels very close to what what
could think is royal music it could sort
of match that space
but then johnny brought the jazz into it
um
which is very much what the character is
experiencing so it's a very free form of
music
um that is based on improvisation and
and other guidelines but it's very free
and can be very
stressed and mad somehow
at the same time very free and unique so
i think that
it really helped i don't know it was a
beautiful approach with with johnny and
whatever he did for the movie
just made it made it what it is and i
i'm happy with it
my last question uh kristen uh
i really enjoy your work and i'm curious
when you are
say you have a really big scene a big
dramatic scene on a monday how are you
actually getting ready for that scene in
advance are you like a week out you're
already thinking about it could you sort
of maybe just take me through your
process
it's different in every circumstance in
every movie in this case we i was i was
running the longer dialogue scenes with
my coach four months in advance
and we kind of
went through the whole script and then
about a week out
as you say of bigger scenes we would
start writing them again
um
but those were really only the ones that
were dialogue heavy if i have like a
really if in this case when we had
something
incredibly heavy
emotionally that wasn't
uh technical because there was no
dialogue in it
um he would he would come in and spring
a scene on me out of nowhere i mean i
think the the most emotional i have ever
got on this whole experience was
when i had absolutely no idea we were
gonna shoot a particular part of the
movie when we did it was the end of a
long day and he was like i think we're
just we're in the hallway we're just
gonna do the part where you run down the
hallway and i was like right now
okay and then suddenly i just like
started losing um my mind and like if i
had to sort of harbor that energy for a
week beforehand it was just would have
um dissipated or or
it you get leaky it's like that emotion
kind of just falls away from you but you
go like
i haven't you thought i mean i'm like
totally chilling i haven't thought about
anything you're doing the biggest scene
right now that's like
that helps but also i had every single
one of these scenes in my fingers and
toes they were sort of at the ready the
whole time i put in so much work before
we started that uh
i never looked at a schedule other than
for the scenes that were very dialogue
heavy but in that even in those cases i
i
i knew everything before we started
shooting and i've never had that
experience before i'm usually kind of
fly by the seat of my pants stand and
deliver type of um
guy
uh it shows in the movie on that note
i'm seriously congrats i wish you guys
nothing but the best hope it's a huge
hit thank you for your time thank you
you